[Music]
good morning class it's Monday February
26th and I'd like to introduce you to my
brother John John this is Billy
come on mr. green Susie morning mr.
green and Tony drop dude now as we all
can see this weekend I underwent a
campaign to decrease the weight of my
head in order to do this I had several
thousand things removed from my head now
most of those things as you might guess
or hairs but some of them were not class
can you guess what else besides hair I
had removed from my head ooh me me yes
Billy burgers it's not actually yeah I
mean I I hadn't actually I'm thought of
that but yeah I did take some burgers
and snow out on my nose mr. green all
right miss Susie my mama came out of
jail she had almost all of her teeth
taken out mm Susie I think that all of
us together if we can practice good oral
hygiene we can avoid such problems no I
didn't have any teeth taken out but good
guess yeah okay Tony I'm gonna guess
earwax um yeah so as Tony somehow
guessed I had a large amount of earwax
removed from my head this weekend and
I'm guessing that its mass was
considerably more than the mass of the
hair that I had removed my head and so
indeed was an effective measure in the
fight to make my head weigh less also
the removal of the earwax ensured that I
could hear again which is very nice
now I actually managed to smuggle my
video camera into the doctor's office
and ask the doctor if I could record the
procedure
and he said no using my wily ways I
convinced the doctor that it was indeed
a good idea to call the attendant out
from the Bobby and record me getting my
ear irrigation I have to warn you that
some of this footage may be disturbing
and may indeed induce nausea I will give
warnings at appropriate times for you to
close your eyes you under some videotape
of the irrigating documentary of his
daily life he's got some serious action
doesn't make it seem as severe as
possible or me oki something happened
that something that just happened was
the earwax popping off my tympanic
membrane as well it's huge oh look at
the birth now we're starting to get
gross so those who are a little bit
squeamish might want to close their eyes
oh I'm really good then I'm gonna be
able to see this oh my god they're
reaching the penultimate grossness so
you should definitely close your eyes
now you guys could be more disgusting
that would be fun okay you could open
your eyes now oh my god I can hear
seriously that was an amazing experience
now I feel like that was almost a
challenge that you should have given me
I go to the doctor's office and have
something a horrible done to you and
videotape it so while I'm feeling like I
just did a challenge I'm gonna give you
one
I wonder if this one's a little gummy
maybe I should go back in so John I
challenge you to find a hat like Miss
Suzy's and while wearing it eat one
teaspoon of horseradish and then sing
the last two lines of the theme song to
blossom I'll see you tomorrow